I'm asked quite a bit these days what
should I follow meaning the person
asking the question slow carb diet or
ketogenic diet and I've talked a lot
about ketosis and ketogenic diet in
tools Titans in the podcast with people
like dom D'Agostino Dominick D'Agostino
among others and various scientists and
MDS here's the answer
I think that 490 plus percent of the
people out there the slow carb diet is
the way to go slow carb diet is still
what I primarily follow when should you
use the ketogenic diet I found the
ketogenic diet most helpful when a I was
suffering from severe symptoms of Lyme
disease which was diagnosed on Long
Island where I had removed 6 embedded
ticks so it was not psychosomatic it
wasn't misdiagnosed and that was the
only thing after a round of course
proper antibiotic treatment in this case
I think it was doxycycline that helped
to mitigate and remove largely the
cognitive decline or effectively
dementia that I felt as well as joint
pain ketones on the candida ketogenic
diet in general have very strong
anti-inflammatory effect and for even
some conditions like say Alzheimer's
there are people who believe if you look
at Alzheimer's as say
type 3 diabetes or brain diabetes as
some people do that when you offer
ketones as an alternate fuel source to a
brain that can no longer metabolize or
utilize glucose properly you can address
many of the symptoms so ketogenic diet
for me is when I have a medical
condition or a problem I cannot seem to
fix via other means I will very
frequently get into a state of ketosis
not through diet per se in terms of
ingesting different foods but actually
fasting and I talk about fasting at
length and different ways to approach it
in tool science I'm not going to belabor
that here the problem with the ketogenic
diet is that if you don't get it
perfectly right it is the worst possible
diet you could follow what do I mean by
that the goal of a ketogenic diet is to
get into a state of
this means that your carbohydrate and
protein consumption is low enough
effectively zero in the case of
carbohydrates and your fat intake is
high enough so we're talking about 75
plus percent of your calories from fat
that your body switches into effectively
a starvation mode where it says we're
not getting the carbohydrates and
nutrients we need to produce a glucose
for the body for the brain and
everything else so we're going to start
converting fat that includes stored fat
that's why you store fat into these
alternate fuel source called ketones
okay this is a very very binary thing so
you are either in ketosis or you are not
and we can measure it with say a finger
prick device called the precision extra
X pra by Abbott Labs and if you are not
say at 0.5 millimolar so that's how the
concentration is measured that's the
number Rita if you're not at 0.5 or
higher and if you're in ketosis
generally people who consider the
fueling the euphoria and the clarity
that you feel at say 1 millimolar or
higher for some people it's even 1.5 or
2 you are in ketosis but a lot of people
and when I say a lot I would say more
than 60% of people who attempt to do
this will fail because they will miss
things like some type of sugar that's in
the mustard they use or they will have
some type of even say non-nutritive
artificial sweetener that for whatever
reason provokes an insulin response or
glucose response or this is a trickier
one they aren't consuming a bunch of
carbohydrates they followed that but
they're eating too much protein and then
the liver turns the extra amino acids
via something called gluconeogenesis
into [ __ ] boot pardon my french glucose
and then you're screwed again so there
are many ways to mess up the ketogenic
diet and if you think you're in ketosis
so you're eating 7080 percent of your
calories from fat but you're actually
using glucose that is arguably the worst
possible by it you could follow your
blood lipid profiles all these blood
markers are going to go way out of whack
so you either get it really really right
or it's a terrible diet so for people
who are very very meticulous very
perhaps OCD like I am and
detail-oriented and can really suffer
through the monotony of that diet it's
great and in extreme cases also there
are many people who think that it can
benefit certain cancer treatments
whether it's chemo radiation etc as an
adjunct to supplement with say fasting
and/or the ketogenic diet typically I
recommend slow carb diet because slow
carb I would say there is an 80% based
on tracking say now at this point
closely tracking more than 2500 people
and certainly observing tens of
thousands of people following this diet
it probably has an 80% compliance rate
meaning over the first the the
percentage of people who can stick with
it for a month is certainly in the 70 to
80 percent range
ketosis and the ketogenic diet I would
say the percentage of people who can
stick with a real strict by necessity
since binary ketogenic diet is going to
be less than 10% okay so less than 10
percent pass rate on doing the ketogenic
diet for a month I think that is very
fair it is really really boring diet to
do properly unfortunately now I get the
benefits of ketosis in a number of other
ways sometimes on days like today where
I've consumed a very very low
carbohydrate small meal I'll have
something like this this is coffee with
some exogenous ketones in it exogenous
meaning outside of the body
so you think exoskeleton EXO outside
exogenous
endogenous produced in the body
exogenous ketones is a liquid that I
pour in here it's called keto force
there are different types and it is beta
hydroxy butyrate it's the same thing
that you measure in your blood with a
finger prick when you are say testing to
see if you're in ketosis or not and that
allows me to jack up my ketone levels
this I think can be misused also more
frequently at least once a month I'm
doing say a three day fast and you want
to do this with medical supervision
folks don't be an amateur doctor I'm not
a doctor don't play one on the internet
let's say from Thursday dinner to Sunday
dinner that's enough time to get into
ketosis briefly and I think there are
other benefits to fasting that might be
related such as triggering autophagy and
deactivating or at least not activating
something called mTOR which talked with
at length on the podcast with a guy a
guy in a very world class scientist who
is shortlisted for the Nobel Prize named
David Sabatini but you guys can listen
to so I think there are benefits that
can be derived incredible benefits from
intermittent ketosis that doesn't
necessarily mean you need to use a
ketogenic diet fasting exogenous ketones
may be a combination of intermittent
fasting plus exaggerated ketones etc is
very valuable as different tools in the
arsenal but for the short answer and I
said this top of this long-winded
explanation as well is that if I take a
hundred people and I just selected at
random from the population I tell them
to do a slow carb diet I would bet on at
least 70% succeeding for a period of two
to four weeks and in that period of time
people who have a fair amount of fat to
lose for instance very common if it's a
someone who weighs more than let's call
call it 200 pounds and more than 15%
body fat that they could use up to 20
pounds of fat this is very very common
it's not always the case but very common
then you take another hundred people you
put them on the ketogenic diet and it's
strict and then they have to self
enforce you're not making food for them
they have to figure it out I would say
you're going to be looking at maximum
20% we're going to make it a month and
in my experience that actually lost more
body fat on the slow carb diet than I
have in ketosis oddly enough because you
would think that you would be portable
in your body fat stores fantastic well
I've done the nine day fast deep deep
ketosis which is already going to be
highly muscle sparing surprisingly
and lost very little fat why would that
be well because each pound of fat is
something along the lines of nine
thousand calories so even if you're very
very lean you're five percent body fat
you have plenty of fat to keep you alive
for a week to three weeks and it's a
slow burn so for whatever reason it
could be microbiome related I suspect it
is that when you're eating prebiotic
foods on the slow carb diet like lentils
legumes etc and also getting a
thermogenic effective food for more
protein intake and it's a diet that's
highly compatible with say power
training and resistance training
different types for whatever reason I
just see more fat loss on slow carbs so
that is not why I use the ketogenic diet
is mainly as a means of improving
cognitive performance and as a medical
intervention so there you have it folks
slow carb diet vs. ketogenic diet hope
that clarifies things when in doubt slow
carb that's it if you enjoyed this video
I want to propose you check out the
podcast the Tim Ferriss show why is it
been number one on iTunes across all
categories in some cases number one in
business why does it have 70 million
plus downloads because I interview
world-class performers from athletics
business that includes billionaires from
everything imaginable entertainment to
tease out the routines the habits the
tools that you can use so check it out
the Tim Ferriss show